okay here's a question for you guys do
you like when you watch youtube and
twitch do you feel like it's part of
your job
to watch it or do you no no i don't i i
still feel like i'm
i'm you know back in 2013 watching my
favorite content creators
well then the changes now is that you
know oh [ __ ] they follow me maybe on
twitter maybe they probably don't but
maybe
i don't know like in a way to me it kind
of
it's like half off for me because it's
like you know there are some
videos that just pop up in my
recommended where i'm just like this is
so
little to do with what i do for a job
yeah that it just becomes entertainment
yeah but then there are parts of me
which are like i could like say watch a
a video idea or a video that has this
particular idea that
i had no idea existed yeah and there's
i'd be lying if i said there wasn't a
part of me
that thinks oh i wonder if i can use
this
idea that this video is using and kind
of spin it in a way for my own content
yeah right it's like
it i'm it's it's not so much like i'm
going out onto youtube
just trying to find the next idea or
whatever but sometimes there are some
videos where it's just like
i could do that but in like a kind of
fun and unique way for myself right yeah
because i do that as well where i watch
youtube i watch twitch i'm constantly
i'm constantly looking for ways to
improve my own content yeah and seeing
stuff seeing some things that i can
maybe like
like not one-on-one ripping someone off
but like taking taking an aspect and
think being like
i can put my own spin on that right like
you know there have been moments where
i've made entire videos based off
ideas from like three or four completely
unrelated videos yeah just kind of being
like i'll take
you know this idea from this video and
this idea from this completely separate
video yeah
and what do you know i've come up with
something kind of cool and unique that i
can work off of as well which is
kind of unique and interesting to my
audience yeah because i i think there's
like it's really looked down upon um
like i don't know if it's just the
creator community or even like when
whenever
with the audience as well whenever you
see something that kind of resembles
someone else you're just like oh you're
just ripping off x or you're just
ripping off why
whereas like i don't know like to me
like artists like musicians
and like you know movie makers they
they're they're like really open
about their influences like like some of
them were the influences on their
sleeves yeah people are just like
cool yeah and i i i don't know why it's
it's
looked down upon in the youtube space
because everyone's exactly the same
everyone's been
influenced by someone else on the
platform and it's really
like the rarer thing is finding someone
who's completely [ __ ] original right
and like even to me some of the biggest
content creators where i in my mind they
were just like
um they they did something completely
like completely original content like
for example like nakey jakey or for
example he's doing something
very very different from what other
people are doing even he says oh yeah
i'm kind of just like jontron
on a green screen and uh i think yeah i
think he's just said i'm just
i'm just the shittier jontron on an
exercise yeah yeah i said in a video and
i'm like
i mean you know you obviously like it's
so obvious you were influenced by
jontron but it doesn't matter because
you're putting your own spin on it in a
unique way you're putting your own
personality on it where now this
supposed thing you ripped off has just
become you yeah yeah right
i mean you know i i already give a [ __ ]
if someone does one of my video ideas
no um i you know that you can 100
just take it um yeah you know if you're
gonna 100
take the idea it would be nice to be
like oh yeah i got this idea from this
person
right yeah uh because if i if i
blatantly copy a video i'll just be like
oh yeah
yeah i mean like who was that person who
just blatantly copied mr beast
for the longest time
i mean like on that level it's so
obvious that it's just kind of like a
kind of like a one-to-one card thumbnail
title it's a little much because you
might be [ __ ] with things there but
like yeah taking the video idea is like
like whatever i mean right i mean i've
seen you know a bunch of youtubers who
have done
videos that you know i have come up with
or i was known for
and but i've been okay with it because
they've put their own spin on it where
it's just kind of become like well i
know where you got influence from but
yeah this has just become your video now
so
i'm [ __ ] okay with it yeah yeah if it
was like one for one like
ripping my like using the same type of
thumbnail using the same type of title
and then the content is almost one for
one and then you don't mention the
person you got it from then yeah i'll be
like well
that's a little bit shitty isn't it like
yeah yeah because like i one one of like
a lot
one of the biggest questions i get asked
is like how how do i go about like a new
content creator is just like
how do i go about making content how do
i go about
making original ideas and finding my own
style and like i always say
you know what stop i don't see any
problem with just
start you know starting by copying some
of your favorite creators
right because you will find your own
style
the more you do your own content right
but it's not something that you
immediately like it's not something that
you immediately figure out and
even like some people do but those are
the rare
rare people yeah those are like the true
geniuses yeah it's like not everyone on
youtube is a genius and i i think it
should be fine for
creators in our fields just to like wear
their influences on their sleeves and
just be open about it
like not completely copying but like
every like you know everyone has their
influences and
everyone continues to evolve from
different people they see on the
platform at least that's how it is with
me
and i think it should be fine you know i
i i think everyone's being influenced
with each other because everyone
yeah i don't know a single youtuber who
doesn't watch youtube
exactly like i mean you know that's the
reason why we're here yeah i mean
you know like i always get reminded of
that uh picasso quote which is like
good artist copy great artist steal
right and like a lot of people
like kind of take that quote completely
out of context thinking like well then
i'll just [ __ ] steal the thing but
like
yeah i actually read up on why he said
that and what he meant by that which is
a great artist steals in the sense that
they take an
influence and they turn it into
something of their own yeah yeah and i
feel that's very valid to
any creative field whether that be an
artist or a movie producer or youtuber
where it's like you can get influenced
by other people
but it's you have to do it to the point
where
you put your own thing on it where it
becomes your own thing
yeah right and that's really hard to do
and you know great artists steal good
artist copy you know yeah
youtubers who just copy an idea but
don't do anything creative with it
are the ones that are just like well
you're a [ __ ] copycat aren't you i i
i think one oh did i say i never really
thought about it much i was just like
i just watched youtube i made my videos
we're getting awfully philosophical
i'm just sitting on my i make [ __ ]
stupid videos it's kind of how like i
view it i'm just like all right i'll
just keep loading the same [ __ ]
i mean yeah i'm like that too but you
know i'd be lying if i said there wasn't
a part of me that
did think about that being like oh god i
mean
this is a cool idea and i want to you
know incorporate and do it because it
just seems like something fun to do
but yeah you know i i sometimes get
worried being like
are people going to come out and be like
how dare you steal this
extra next idea right like i think about
stuff like that and then i just also
remember like some of the most popular
videos are like
pee pee poo poo stinky and like that
shouting sound effect
so like the moment i try and get all
like deep about i'm like i don't think
it's that deep i think it's
people uploading stuff that makes them
hehe xd yeah yeah
i don't [ __ ] know i mean i i i do
think you register it
at least consciously i definitely do
yeah because i i feel like
you know when people ask how do you like
what does it take to become a successful
youtuber a lot of things that are well
the one thing a lot of
people think a lot of like the one thing
that a lot of people don't mention
is that step one i feel like it's to
watch a lot of youtube
well yeah of course like no no because i
mean i mean you
you say of course but i know people who
don't watch too much youtubers or
if i'm just like name 10 to like name 10
to 20 years
they see youtube on the news they're
like oh i want to be a youtuber yeah
yeah yeah yeah
and i i feel like not a lot of people
talk about a lot of
youtubers i know they watch a [ __ ] ton
of youtube right
it feels like there's so many subtle
things that you can't really explain to
someone
unless they just understand the platform
because they watch a [ __ ] ton of
youtubers it's not just
watching a [ __ ] on a youtubers it's
watching a [ __ ] ton of different
youtubers yeah yeah exactly
it's like i could be like name 10 you
know youtubers and if all of them are
the same type of
content then it's like well you
understand that type of content
yeah everything else is just a complete
blank to you right yeah you're probably
not going to go very far because that
would
be just be recycling the same content
from those 10 youtubers yeah
or oh it's just like watching youtubers
who are popular like
five years ago right i still watch ray
william johnson every day
i strive to be i strive to make my own
equals three one day
my day doesn't begin without william
and yeah i i just i just think you know
the the idea
of like yes i would like to become a
youtuber because they are successful now
and you know
they make lots of money for an easy job
yeah yeah and i i feel like step one
before you even
consider becoming a youtuber or a
streamer
is just to watch a [ __ ] ton of things on
that night no no no step one is delete
your twitter history
you don't want to get canceled it's
pretty good yeah get rid of that
privatization
step two is watching privatize your
facebook delete your twitter
yeah because i i mean that's how i feel
about like instagram and tick tock
because i don't use those platforms and
i'm not gonna try to
grow on those platforms because i feel
like you don't use it right because the
first step is i don't understand it so
it's kind of like to me it's just like
that
hello fellow instagrammers kind of thing
if i try to like you just turn into one
of those corporate brands right yeah
yeah
it's like yes we understand you there's
more picture of my food that's what you
all like right
why are you liking it